okay yeah talk about Agora okay you want
to hear about it okay so Agora is is
what it's a b2b paid newsletter company
yeah has absurd revenue go to my Twitter
account
okay so here's another interesting
company I know this because I'm in this
world and it's directly related to us
yeah just yeah the same par yeah
whatever that's fine
okay so Agora crazy interesting
background so Agora was started by this
guy named Bill Bonner in the 1970s he
was a publisher he had a magazine about
money and investing and things like that
and then he decided to start changing
how we did his marketing and he created
a newsletter that would became quite
popular at this point it you'll see it's
the most popular one no up higher at
this point they make it's rumored to be
one and a half to two billion dollars a
year and the way that they do this there
it is
they own 20 to 40 different newsletter
publishers and what they do is is they
buy a ton of traffic to their funnels
their marketing funnels and right off
the bat they'll sell you a fifty dollar
product right and once you buy that
fifty dollar product they now have a
large database and email list of
qualified buyers who are interested in a
particular topic and they typically lose
money on this first purchase so let's
say that they have a book that's 50
bucks they'll spend up to two hundred
dollars to acquire you meaning they'll
buy ten of ads and they'll lose money on
you but they'll make it up because on
that they call a back end on the back
end they sell you a two thousand dollar
paid newsletter and this company in
particular they even sell supplements
and now some people think that they
some people love them and when you own
twenty or forty different brands you're
gonna have some legitimately great
products right so what's their best
product money map press.com
or yeah money map press this is for
hedge funds for a financial trader no
yes some financial traders they're their
typical audience is white men between 50
seventy who-who-who are conservative and
believe in like the government's gonna
come and like take your money I mean
that goes like so I sign up some of
their funnels and there was like if
you go to Breitbart comm you'll see an
ad it says like Nancy Pelosi's coming
for your money and things like that and
you sign it takes you through one of the
Agora and it's a five dollar book and
then yeah and then you'll you'll go
through these funnels if now let's just
get rid of the whole unethical part
because you can learn from everyone who
cares if it's unethical or ethical it's
fascinating regardless and you can learn
from it what they're experts at is
copywriting and everyone in Silicon
Valley not everyone but you know you get
the point it's all about design it's
kind of look good it's gotta be
aesthetic their websites are a blank
page with text right not just text but
like 5,000 words in a buy now
button at the very bottom its value
fascinating that is fascinating and I
think you're you know you know that
Peter teal quote where it's like what's
something you believe to be true that
for you would agree with you on yeah I
feel like you know you might have many
but one of them would be copywriting
over design any day
copywriting over design 100% most people
when I learned the word copywriting
those like what does what does copy why
does everyone keep saying this and like
I literally was at work and people like
hey can you give me some copy as a
coffee what she just asked me to go get
a coffee for her like I had no idea what
the she was talking about and and
then I sort of learned Oh copy means
text that's gonna come on the website
and then through you I realized hey wait
a minute the text that's on your website
is essentially your sales man and sales
gives you the money I probably learn how
to do this not am I waiting deep on it
it's the most important skill you can
learn because I've spent years learning
it if you just give me a blank page I
will I will make money till I die right
I will always have a job because I could
do that right now what I could do is do
really unethical and scam a lot of
people really easily but if you know how
to copyright do you know how to persuade
via the written word yeah I would say
persuasion is the most important skill
whether it's through the written word
verbally you know I don't know if
there's some of you have a copyright
variation copywriting just the form in
which you learn it now the way that I
describe it is if you're a good
copywriter you underst
dan what motivates people and if you
understand what motivates people you can
create products that they'll want that
will appeal to people yeah and then if
you are kind that is that's the when you
do copywriting you just learn what
motivates people and then you just
happen to use the written word to write
communicate yeah
when when you mentioned the boron
letters and then I just went deep on
that that was like my foray into this so
we'll do a whole section on did you read
the copyright yes and then I started
like doing all the things in it because
I got obsessed
so the boron letters if anyone's curious
Gary Halbert is his name he's dead now
he died of a heart attack she kind of
hard to find it's hard to find but
there's one link and if you get to it's
like chapter 1 2 3 19 or whatever it's
this copywriter who's one of the best
copy writers of all time and what he
would do is he was such a good
copywriter that he kind of turned into a
crook and so he would write these sales
letters to buy like encyclopedias or and
buy like anything just so
the boron letters are the way it starts
it's like he's writing to his son he's
in jail he's in jail writing to his son
and he doesn't start off by being like
here's how you copy right he's just
writing to his son and it's one by one
and each one's a teaser every sentence
teases the next sentence and every
letter teases the next letter and then
by the time you get 20 deep you're like
this guy's a master it is awesome
[Music]
you